WELCOME BACK MEMBERS DOCTOR
QUIRK NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A
QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER BRING THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
ACOSTA AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
ALLEN ARAMBULA BAKER.
BERMAN BIGELOW BLOOM.
BONTA BROUGH BURKE CABALLERO
CALDERON CARRILLO CERVANTES CHAU
CHAVEZ CHEN.
DAVID CHIU CHOI KANSEN CHU
[inaudible]
COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
SALLY [inaudible]
DAILY [inaudible]
EGGMAN FLORA FONG [inaudible]
FRAZIER.
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL.
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ FLETCHER
GRAY [inaudible]
GRAYSON HARPER HOLDEN IRWIN
JONES SAWYER KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE
KILEY LACKEY LEVINE LIMON OWN
[inaudible]
LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN.
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL PATTERSON
QUIRK.
QUIRK SILVA REYES RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO.
STEINORTH STONE [inaudible]
THURMOND TEEN VOEPEL WALDRON
WEBER WOOD MISTER SPEAKER
.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK THAT OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER.
AND IN THE GALLERY.
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN THE
REVEREND BOB OSHITA [inaudible]
REVENUE OSHA.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
ALTHOUGH THE WORLD HAS ADVANCED
TECHNOLOGICALLY MORE IN THE LAST
SEVEN DECADES THEN IN THE LAST
SEVEN CENTURIES.
AS A SPECIES WE HUMAN BEINGS
HAVE YET TO LEARN HOW TO LIVE
TOGETHER IN PEACE.
IN REFLECTING ON THE BOMBING OF
HIROSHIMA SEVENTY THREE YEARS
AGO TODAY.
WE REMEMBER AGAIN THAT WE MUST
LEARN TO LIVE TOGETHER IN PEACE.
FOR HUMANKIND CAN NOW EASILY
DESTROY LIFE ON EARTH AS WE KNOW
IT.
I REMEMBER MY FIRST VISIT TO
HIROSHIMA AND THE PEACE MEMORIAL
IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE MY AUNTIE
TOIL CHO WHO LIVED THROUGH THE
BOMBING ASK ME.
HOW WAS IT?
I SAID IT WAS UNBELIEVABLE.
SHE SMILED AND SAID WHAT YOU SAW
TODAY WAS NOTHING.
SHE EXPLAINED IN NINETEEN FORTY
FIVE THIS PART OF FEWER SHIMA
WITH HIS COUNTRYSIDE WITH RICE
FIELDS EXTENDING UPHILL FIGHT.
AND ON THAT MORNING WE HEARD A
LARGE EXPLOSION.
AND WE ALL RUSHED OUTSIDE TO SEE
WHAT HAPPENED.
SHE SAID WE WERE AMAZED TO SEE
SUCH A BEAUTIFUL CLOUDS
BILLOWING OVER HIROSHIMA.
WE WONDERED WHAT COULD HAVE
CREATED SUCH A BEAUTIFUL CLOUD.
THEN WE NOTICES SMALL FIRE HAD
STARTED ON A ROOF.
BUT WE HAD TO LAUGH.
BECAUSE IT WAS SO STRANGE.
NOT JUST OUR ROOF BUT EVERY ROOF
OF THE FEW HOMES THAT DOTTED THE
WHOLE FIGHT.
WAS ON FIRE EXACTLY THE SAME WAY.
WE WONDERED HOW CAN THIS BE.
WE ADMIRED THE CLOUDS AND WE
LAUGHED IN DISBELIEF.
AT THE UNCANNY FIRES.
WE WERE SO INNOCENT.
IT WAS LIKE A STRANGE DREAM
[inaudible]
ONLY LATER.
DID THEY LEARN THAT A NIGHTMARE
HAD HAPPENED.
SHE WENT INTO DETAIL TELLING ME
ABOUT THE WALKING DEAD THAT
FLAYED HIROSHIMA.
BADLY BURNED.
JOAQUIN CHALK.
WITH BEACON AYE ASKING FOR WATER.
AND SHE SAID WHEN WE TRY TO GIVE
THEM WATER.
THEY JUST KEPT WALKING BY NOT
SEEING US AT ALL.
THEN SHE ADDED.
WHAT YOU SAW TODAY WAS NOTHING?
BUT IT WAS ENOUGH FOR ME.
AND IT SHOULD BE ENOUGH FOR ALL
HUMANITY.
REFLECTING ON THE ATOMIC BOMBING
OF HIROSHIMA AND NAGASAKI
SEVENTY THREE YEARS AGO.
LET US REDEDICATE OURSELVES I
KEEP THE DREAM OF WORLD PEACE A
LIFE WITH ENOUGH.
WORLD PEACE BEGINS WITH EACH OF
US.
WORLD PEACE BEGINS WITH MY
PATIENTS MY KINDNESS IN MY PEACE
OF MIND.
HEALING THE WOUNDS OF HATE
BEGINS WITH ME.
HOPE FOR A BETTER WORLD.
NOW MORE NEED THEM.
BUT KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE
BEYOND.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING.
AND JOINING US FOR THE FLAG
SALUTE PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA.
AS HE LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE
MISTREATMENT PLEASE JOIN ME IN
THE PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE READY
BEGIN.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE.
THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO THURSDAY JULY 262018%
TO THE PROVISIONS OF GENERAL
THIRTY NINE THE BALLING ASSEMBLY
JOURNAL FOR THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN REGULAR SESSION WAS
PRINTED WILL ASSEMBLY WAS IN
SUMMER RECESS.
BUT TELECOMMUNICATIONS
REPRESENTED BY THE SPEAKER AND
ORDERED PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
DEAR MISTER WILLSON INITIALIZER
CALDERON MOVES.
AND MS BAKER SECONDS OF THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION REFERENCE OF BILLS
WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR THE
DAY. FOR PERSONAL BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
CARILLO.
ALSO FOR PERSONAL BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS REEVE US.
AND MELINDA HAS.
MEMBERS WE ARE A PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTION SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN A TO ALLOW THE SPEAKER
AND A SEVEN COOLEY.
SAWYER TO HAVE GUESTS AND
PHOTOGRAPHERS THE FLOOR TODAY
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ARAMBULA AND
JONES SAWYER IS GAS WILL BE
SEATED AT THEIR DAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE ALLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS GIPSON BURKE.
HOLDEN AND VOEPEL TO SPEAK ON A
GERMAN IN MEMORY TODAY.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
REMOVE ITEM ONE TWENTY TWO S. B.
FIFTEEN TEN SENATE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNANCE OF FINANCE FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
THE CLERK WILL KNOW.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SIX PLEASE WITHDRAW S. B. NINE
THIRTY ONE HERTZBERG FROM THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE IN
ORDER THE BILL TO SECOND READING
FILE THE BILL IS NON FISCAL.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER I AM GIVING A ONE DAY
NOTICE TO REMOVE THE FOLLOWING
BILLS FROM THE INACTIVE FILE.
I'M A THIRTEEN SB SEVEN NINETY
MCGUIRE.
ITEM A EIGHTEEN S. B. FIVE
SEVENTY THREE LADA.
AND ITEM A TWENTY THREE SB SIX
OR SEVEN SKINNER.
THE CLERK WILL AGAIN NO.
THE CLERK WILL KNOW THE ONE DAY
NOTICE.
AND MEMBERS PURSUANT.
TO ASSEMBLY RULE SEVENTY SEVEN
POINT.
TWO I AM REFERRING ITEM NUMBER.
FORTY ONE AB SIX FIFTY THREE
CUNNINGHAM TO THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE AND THEN TO
THE HEALTH COMMITTEE
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE LOTS OF GAS WITH
US IN THE CHAMBER TODAY MEMBERS.
MEMBERS IF WE KEEP THE VOLUME
LEVEL DOWN IN THE CHAMBER.
WE HAVE GUESTS WITH US TODAY.
WHERE TO BEGIN WITH DOCTOR
ARAMBULA FROM YOUR DESK WITH
YOUR SPECIAL GAS INTRODUCTION
DOCTOR ARAMBULA?
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
I RISE TODAY TO RECOGNIZE THE
GAS VISITING FROM MY DISTRICT IS
THAT THE GAS TIME INTRODUCING OR
IS IT MY SPECIAL GUESTS DOWN
BELOW.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS MISTER DOCTOR
ARAMBULA WEST FRESNO FAMILY
RESOURCE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER.
TODAY WE HAVE THE HONOR OF
WELCOMING MORE THAN FORTY
STUDENTS PARENTS AND STAFF.
FROM THE WEST FAMILY RESOURCE
CENTER.
ALSO IN THE GALLERY IS THE STAFF
FROM THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
THE OFFICE OF HEALTH EQUITY.
THE STUDENTS VISITING HERE TODAY
FROM WEST FRESNO ARE
PARTICIPATING IN THE SWEET
POTATO PROJECT.
THIS PROGRAM IS MADE POSSIBLE BY
THE CALIFORNIA REDUCING
DISPARITIES PROJECT A STATE
FUNDED FIVE YEAR PILOT PROGRAM.
DESIGNED TO REDUCE DISPARITIES
AND TO IMPROVE THE MENTAL HEALTH
OF CHILDREN IN THE UNDERSERVED
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
THE SWEET POTATO PROJECT IS
AIMED AT PREVENTING AND REDUCING
SCHOOL DROP OUT AND GANG
INVOLVEMENT IN SUBSTANCE.
ABUSE INITIATION AMONG AFRICAN
AMERICAN YOUTH IN WEST FRESNO.
THROUGH THIS EFFORT THE WEST
FRIEND FRESNO FAMILY RESOURCE
CENTER IS PROVIDING
OPPORTUNITIES TO INCREASE
AFRICAN AMERICAN YOUTH
ENGAGEMENT.
IN THE COMMUNITY. TO ENCOURAGE
EDUCATIONAL ATTAINMENTS PROVIDE
MENTORSHIP AND TO PROVIDE
LEADERSHIP DEVELOPMENT.
NOW IN THE PROJECTS SECOND YEAR
THE STUDENTS ARE PLANNING
PLANTING AND GROWING SWEET
POTATOES AND DEVELOPING A SWEET
POTATO BASED PRODUCT TO TAKE TO
MARKET.
ALL WHILE TAKING
ENTREPRENEURSHIP CLASSES AT THE
LISLE CENTER AT FRESNO STATE.
THE WEST FRESNO FAMILY RESOURCE
CENTER HAS BEEN A SUCCESSFUL
POSITIVE GROWING.
SPURIOUS FOR THE STUDENTS THAT
YOU SEE BEFORE YOU HERE TODAY.
THESE STUDENTS ARE OBTAINING A
VALUABLE BUSINESS EXPERIENCE
PRACTICING TEAM MARKED IN
GAINING CONFIDENCE IN THEMSELVES
DOUBLE AS PERSPIRE INSPIRE THEM
TO GREAT HEIGHTS.
I CONGRATULATE THE STUDENTS ON
THEIR HARD WORK AND THANK THEM
FOR THEIR PARTICIPATION IN THIS
WE POTATO PROJECT.
WHEN I WAS EXPLAINING THIS
PROJECT AT HOME THIS MORNING TO
MY DAUGHTER?
SHE GREW EXCITED.
EXCITED ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COME AND THANK FELLOW STUDENTS
WHO COME FROM MY COMMUNITY WHO
GIVE BACK TO MY COMMUNITY AND
WHO ARE PLANTING THE SEEDS THAT
MAKE THE DIFFERENCE FOR
LEADERSHIP.
IN MY COMMUNITY IF YOU COULD
HELP ME TO WELCOME THE STUDENTS
OF THE WEST FRESNO FAMILY
RESOURCE CENTER AS WELL AS MY
DAUGHTER.
WHO CAME UP HERE FROM FRESNO
HERE TODAY AND THANK THEM FOR
THEIR PARTICIPATION IN THIS
PROGRAM
?
MEMBERS I SEE MISTER SPEAKER ON
THE FLOOR.
MEMBERS.
PLEASE GIVE YOUR ATTENTION. TO
MISTER SPEAKER MISTER SPEAKER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS MEMBERS
IT IS NOW MY PLEASURE TO
INTRODUCE SOMEONE WHO HAS
THROUGH HER HARD WORK.
PRODUCED A LARGE AND SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT ON OUR STATE. THIRTY FIVE
YEARS AGO CHERYL PARISI BROUGHT
ABOUT A DIFFERENT KIND OF ME TO
MOVEMENT.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE OR
ORGANIZING OF LOW WAGE
LIBRARIANS AND CLERICAL STAFF IN
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES.
ESTABLISHED A MEASURE OF PAY
EQUITY TO COUNTER GENDER
DISPARITIES IN COMPENSATION.
SINCE THEN SHE BECAME EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF ASKED ME COUNCIL.
THIRTY SIX AND BUILT IT INTO
WHAT IS TODAY A BULWARK FOR THE
RIGHTS OF WORKING PEOPLE.
I'M PROUD TO SAY SHE HAILS FROM
BOW AND IS A GRADUATE OF THE
HIGH SCHOOL.
GO EAGLES.
ARE ONE OF THE CITY'S IN MY
DISTRICT AND I AM SAD TO SEE HER
RETIRE FOR MASS ME LETTERS ALL
WELCOME SARAH PARISI IN WHICH
ARE WELL ON THE NEXT PHASE OF
MERGER
.
MEMBERS THAT YOU HAVE YOUR
ATTENTION I SEE A FORMER MEMBER
OF THIS HOUSE.
SOMEONE WHO MISSES THE ASSEMBLY
VERY MUCH.
NOWCONGRESSMAN JIMMY GOMEZ IS
ON THE FLOOR CONGRESSMAN
.
AND MR GRAYSON MISTER GRAYSON
YOU HAVE GUESTS WITH US TODAY
[inaudible]
MISTER GRAYSON.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
IN THE GALLERY TODAY WE HAVE
SAILORS FROM THE USS EMORY S.
LAND WHICH HAS BEEN DOCKED AT
MARE ISLAND SINCE MAY.
WHILE THE SHIP UNDERGOES REPAIR
AND MAINTENANCE THIS SHIP IS ONE
OF TWO SUBMARINE TENDERS THAT
THE U. S. NAVY OPERATES AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY. FOR THE COMMUNITY
OF VALLEJO IT IS THE FIRST
ACTIVE DUTY SHIP TO DOCK AT MARE
ISLAND SINCE THE SHIP GOT SHUT
DOWN IN.
NINETEEN NINETY SIX THE DOCKING
OF THE U. S. S. EMORY S. LAND.
AND ITS CREW OF OVER FOUR
HUNDRED SAILORS IS A PROUD
REMINDER OF THE LABEL'S HERITAGE
AND CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR
NATION'S SECURITY.
THROUGHOUT ONE HUNDRED YEARS OF
ACTIVE DUTY MARE ISLAND NAVAL
SHIPYARD CONSTRUCTED AT LEAST
EIGHTY NINE SEA GOING VESSELS.
INCLUDING SEVENTEEN NUCLEAR
POWERED SUBMARINES HAVING AN
ACTIVE DUTY SHIP BACK AT OUR
DOCKS HAS BROUGHT OUR COMMUNITY
TOGETHER AND THEREFORE ON BEHALF
OF THE ENTIRE COMMUNITY OF
VALLEJO.
I WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME THE CREW
OF THE USS EMORY S. LAND TO MARE
ISLAND AND I ASKED MY COLLEAGUES
THAT YOU PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING THEM. TO THE ASSEMBLY
TODAY
.
MISTER JONES SAWYER YOU HAVE A
VIP ON THE FLOOR WITH US TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
[inaudible]
AND TODAY I HAVE THE HONOR.
OF PRESENTING SOMEONE WHO IS NO
STRANGER TO DIS FLOOR.
HE WAS HERE IN.
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN I WAS A LOT
TALLER THAN HE IS AND THEN HE IS
NOW.
AND IT'S MY SON HAD BEEN PRINTED
JONES SAWYER.
HE JUST FINISHED AP CALCULUS.
AT AND PRE CALPERS I'M SORRY
PRECALCULUS.
AND AS A GIFT TO HIM ICE DECIDED
TO BRING HIM HERE TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY AND
HAVE SPEND THE WEEK WITH ME.
HE WANTED PASSED BUT I THOUGHT
THIS WAS A LOT BETTER.
EVAN BRENDA JONES SAWYER
.
MEMBERS PLEASE DIRECT YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER TO MY DESK MISTER COOPER.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
SPECIAL PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
TODAY IT IS MY HONOR TO
RECOGNIZE CANINE BLUE AND ITS
HANDLER AUTHOR DISSIMILAR OF THE
L. GROW PLEASED TO PASS. FOR THE
HEROIC ACTIONS DISPLAYED LONG
PURSUIT OF TWO ARMED ROBBERIES
SUSPECTS.
ON THE EVENING OF JANUARY
SEVENTH TWENTY SEVENTEEN OFFICER
MILLER AND CAN A BLUE RESPONDED
TO A ROBBERY AT A LOCAL BUSINESS
IN MY HOME CITY OF EL GROW.
WHEN THEY ARRIVED?
MEMBERS PLEASE IT DOES NOT
PLEASE.
WHEN THEY ARRIVED ALSO REAL
OBSERVE TO OUR MEN FLEEING THE
SCENE IT WAS TIME OFFICER MILLER
DEPLOYED KING I BLOOM TO STOP
THE CRIMINALS?
CAN A BLUE FLUID ACTUALLY.
RECEIVED AS LIFE SUFFER TWO
GUNSHOT WOUNDS.
IT IS A TYPICAL SHE SUSPECTS.
AFTER SHOOTING BLUES BLEEDING
DOLLARS LEFT LEG AND WAS RUSHED
CO THROUGH THE HOSPITAL WE WAS
TREATED.
AFTER A MOTHER RECOVERY CAN AND
WILL RETURN TO WORK LEADER HAD
RETIRED DUE TO THE INJURIES HE
SUSTAINED.
ON JULY TWENTY SEVEN CAN ALSO
BLUE WAS PRESENTED WITH A PURPLE
HEART BUDGET BY NOW THAT.
THE CEREMONY THE BILL GROWTH
HONORING AUTHOR CANINES BLUE
RETIREMENT.
BECAUSE ALSO MILLIKEN A BLUES
COURAGEOUS ACTIONS THE ROBBERS
RELATED APPREHENDED AND WERE
RECENTLY CONVICTED BY A JURY FOR
ATTEMPTED MURDER.
AND HARMING A PLEASE CANINE OF
THESE DOGS ALL THEY CARE ABOUT
IS GOING TO WORK AND THEY'RE
HAPPY EVERY DAY.
AND THE REWARDS THIS TOY TO CHEW
ON A PLAYOFF THAT'S ON THE
BLUE IS A GROWTH POLICE CHIEF
BRIAN DAHLE THAT.
NELSON MILLER'S WIFE CASEY
MILLER AS WILL FEEL GROWTH.
AUTHORED MILLER'S PARTNERS AND
KEEP HIM AND YOU KNOW GROWTH
PLEASE STAND UP GUYS.
I'M SORRY IN IN WOMEN.
MEN AND WOMEN [inaudible]
THE DOW.
SO SINCE THEN ALSO MILLER OF THE
NEW K. NINE DOG NAMED.
NAME ROCKY'S IN TRAINING RIGHT
NOW HOPEFULLY WITH THE STREET
ONE DAY SO MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN
ME IN COMMANDING OFFICER MILLER
THEY CAN I BLEW FOR THEIR
BRAVERY AND SERVICE TO OUR GREAT
STATE
.
AND MISS YOUR EDUARDO GARCIA YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR DESK FOR
YES INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE
A GROUP OF NINE STUDENT FROM.
MAKDESSI BECAUSE THAT BY A THEY
ARE COMING FROM ALL OVER
IMPERIAL COUNTY.
THEY ARE PART OF WILL MEET THIS
CYNICAL THAN MY IS.
PROGRAM CALLED THE YOUTH
ENVIRONMENT HEALTH INTERNSHIP IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
FUNDED BY THE NATIONAL INSTITUTE
OF HEALTH.
THESE INTERNSHIPS FOCUS ON
PREPARING HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
AROUND THE PER COUNTY TO BECOME
THE NEXT LEADERS IN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH.
ARENA THEY ARE SITTING DIRECTLY
ABOVE FROM ME. TO THE WEST LEMON
ASKED HIM TO STAND UP A POLICE
SAY HELLO TO THE STUDENTS SYDNEY
OF FELLOW FREE THAT I MANY GOT
OUT ON THIS ON HIM MICHELLE AND
MICHAEL.
PLEASE HELP ME WELCOME THEM FROM
PALE COUNTY.
MEMBERS WE ARE NOW GOING TO MOVE
TO A CEREMONY HONORING OUR
SCIENCE FELLOWS [inaudible]
MR COOLEY.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FROM MY DESK
IN THE NUMBER [inaudible]
MISTER COOLEY.
COLLEAGUES IT IS NOTABLE THAT ON
THIS DAY THAT WE ARE REMINDED OF
THE ANNIVERSARY.
OF THE FIRST ATOMIC WEAPON
DROPPED IN CONFLICT.
THAT TODAY WE HONOR OUR SCIENCE
FELLOWS HERE IN THE STATE
ASSEMBLY.
THESE ARE FOLKS HAVE
DISTINGUISHED THEMSELVES BEFORE
THEY ARRIVED HERE.
MY ACADEMIC WORK.
EARNING THEM A P. H. D. IN
VARIOUS FIELDS.
SCIENCE AND TECHNOLOGY PLAYS A
KEY ROLE IN OUR ECONOMY.
AND REALLY IN CALIFORNIA'S
NATIONAL AND GLOBAL LEADERSHIP.
AND INCREASINGLY AS ESSENTIAL
ROLE IN LEGISLATION WE DEBATE
HERE ON THE FLOOR.
WE WANT TO THANK OUR SCIENCE
FELLOWS [inaudible]
PROGRAM.
THROUGH ITS WHERE IT WILL JOIN
THE BENEFIT OF THEIR LEARNING.
AND ADD TO THE WORK THAT WE DO
ON LEGISLATION.
SO THAT WE ARE NOT.
BEHIND THE TIMES WERE ABLE TO
BRING THE LATEST.
FIELDS OF STUDY TO BEAR ON
PUBLIC POLICY SERVING THE FUTURE
OF CALIFORNIA.
AS A SHARE THEIR SPECIAL
KNOWLEDGE AND MAKE CONTRIBUTIONS
TO THE PUBLIC POLICY OF OUR
STATE.
TODAY COLLEGE WHO RECOGNIZE
SYNTEX TWENTY EIGHTEEN SCIENCE
FELLOWS. FOR THEIR CONTRIBUTIONS.
AND I NOW ASK THE CLERK TO READ
THE NAMES OF THE SCIENCE FELLOWS
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE.
DOCTOR KEEP CELLINO SERVED IN
THE ASSEMBLY WATER PARKS AND
WILDLIFE COMMITTEE IT'S ONLY
MEMBERS EDUARDO GARCIA GALLAGHER
HER CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR.
HE WILL THE PHD AND AND AS AN
ENVIRONMENTAL SCIENCE FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF MASSACHUSETTS
BOSTON AND THE SOL UNIVERSITY OF
PENNSYLVANIA.
DOCTOR DILLON TOPPLE SERVED IN
THE ASSEMBLY NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MERCILESSLY AND
ACOSTA OUR CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR
HE WILL THE PHD ENVIRONMENTAL
SITE POLICY IN.
BERKELEY AND IT BE A IN
ENVIRONMENTAL STUDIES
[inaudible]
TO CREWS.
DILLON IS NOT ABLE TO BE WITH US
TODAY -- SO
WE WILL PRESS ON BUT DILLON
CHAPEL WAS WITH AS SAID THE
NATURAL RESOURCE COMMITTEE
CONTRIBUTED TO OUR WORK.
JUST UNAVAILABLE TO BE WITH US
TODAY SO WE WILL MOVE ON DOCTOR
NAOMI ON DRASTIC CERTAIN THE
ASSEMBLY EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS O'DONNELL AND
KILEY ARE CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR
YOU'LL THE PHD AN INTEGRATIVE
BIOLOGY FOR YOU THE BERKELEY AND
IF YES A BIOLOGY FROM RANDOLPH
MACON WOMAN'S COLLEGE IN
VIRGINIA.
DOCTOR EAGLE SINCE IRVINE THAT
ASSEMBLY ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY
AND TOXIC MATERIALS COMMITTEE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SPORKIN MELENDEZ
OUR CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR KILL
THE PHD IN CHEMICAL PHYSICS A
HARVARD UNIVERSITY AND COMPLETED
A PHD MINOR AND SCIENCE
TECHNOLOGY [inaudible]
CITING STUDIES THE HARVARD
KENNEDY SCHOOL OF GOVERNMENT.
HE ALSO WITH AT BE S. CHEMISTRY
FROM UC BERKELEY.
DR SANDRA NOT THE GALA SERVED IN
THE ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER STUNNING CUNNING.
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR YOU PHD IN
SOCIOLOGY FROM FOR UNIVERSITY.
SHE RECEIVED DUAL BACHELOR'S
DEGREES THE SOCIOLOGY AND IN
ENGLISH FOR ME THE BERKELEY.
DOCTOR MONICA MONTANA SERVED IN
THE ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS WHAT A MAYES ARE
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR.
SHE HOLDS A PHD IN CELLULAR AND
MOLECULAR PATHOLOGY FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF US MADISON.
AS SHE RECEIVED HER B. S.
BIOLOGY FOR IRAQ CHRIS
UNIVERSALLY MISSOURI.
MEMBERS THROUGHOUT THE CHAMBER
WE ARE JOINED BY THOSE WHO RUN
THE SCIENCE FELLOWS PROGRAM.
AND THE FAMILY AND FRIENDS OF
THE SCIENCE FELLOWS THEMSELVES
WE WELCOME YOU ALL TO THE
ASSEMBLYAND AS WE CONCLUDE OUR
CEREMONY.
LET'S GIVE THE SCIENCE FELLOWS
ONE MORE ROUND OF APPLAUSE
TRANSACTIONS
.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING CORKERY.
SENATE BILL 894-224-95414
531-741-12912 FORTY FOUR THREE
TWENTY SEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS
EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT WITH THE
MAMMOTH ELEVEN TWENTY ONE WITH
THE MOMENT ELEVEN NINETY FOURTH
AMENDMENT'S ONE EIGHTY THREE
WITH AMENDMENTS FOR NINETEEN
WITH MOMENTS ONE HUNDRED
AMENDMENTS SEVENTY WHAT'S
AMENDMENTS AND ELEVEN EIGHTY TWO
WITH AMENDMENTS.
ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ
AND ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE.
ON THE CONCURRENCE FILE.
THIS IS CONCURRENCE WHILE ITEM.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN AND NINETEEN
PASS AND RETAIN.
MEMBERS WEIRD FILE ITEM NUMBER.
TWENTY THIS IS AB [inaudible]
FOR FIFTY SIX THURMAN CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR FIFTY SIX BY
SOME THE NUMBER THURMOND AND
ACTUALLY THE HEALING ARTS.
MR THURMAN YOU MAY OPEN.
I THINK IT IS A SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT.
EIGHTY FOUR FIVE SIX FOR
CONCURRENCE A THIS IS A BILL
THAT WILL ALLOW --
RECENT SOCIAL WORK GRADUATES TO
BE ABLE TO BEGIN THEIR SERVICE --
SOONER OTHERS OFTEN A DELAY IN
THE TIME THAT IT TAKES FOR
SOCIAL WORKER TO GET WHAT'S
CALLED.
A BOARD BEHAVIORAL SERVICES
SCIENCES NUMBER THIS BILL ALLOWS
THOSE WHO I HAVE GRADUATED TO
START A SURVEY NINETY DAYS.
BEFORE THEY CAN RECEIVE THEIR
BBS NUMBER SO THAT WE CAN CUT
DOWN ON THE LAYS IN SERVICE TO
THOSE WHO NEED ACCESS TO A
SOCIAL WORKER.
THE PRACTICE ALREADY ADMITTED
FOR PEOPLE WITH THE MASSES AND
FAMILY THERAPY AND THIS WILL
HELP -- TO
DECREASE THE WAITING TIMES FOR
THOSE IN NEED A SOCIAL WORKER I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MINSI NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
QUIRK GLOBAL THE ROLL-ON ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT ABOUT
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF ANTI SEMITIC
TO NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
FILE AND TWENTY ONE IS AB SIX
THIRTY SIX COOPERATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX THIRTY SIX BY
SOME A MEMBER IRWIN AND ACTUALLY
TRANSPORTATION.
MISSOURI WHEN.
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB SIX THREE
SIX CHANGE THE DATE FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO SUBMIT THE
REQUIRED ANNUAL EXPENDITURE
REPORTS FOR STREETS IN ROSE BY
DECEMBER FIRST OF EVERY YEAR.
THIS WILL ALLOW FOR MORE
ACCURATE DATA TO BE SUBMITTED TO
THE CONTROLLER ENSURE THAT
CITIES AND COUNTIES HAVE ENOUGH
TIME TO REPORT AND PREPARE.
THESE UP TO PREPARE AND AUDIT
THESE REPORTS.
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER ONE SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
QUIRK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SEVENTY
TWO NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM.
TWENTY TWO A. B. SIX SIX SIX
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX SIXTY SIX BY
SOME THE NUMBER AGUIAR-CURRY AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO ELECTIONS
MS AGUIAR-CURRY YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS A. B. SIX SIX SIX IS
BACK FROM THE SENATE FOR
CONCURRENCE WITH AMENDMENTS THAT
ALLOW CANDIDATES. TO SUBMIT THE
CANDIDATE STATEMENT FORM FROM
THEIR HOME COUNTY TO ALL THE
OTHER COUNTIES IN THE DISTRICT.
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
PASSED OUT THE SENATE
UNANIMOUSLY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS SAGER CURRY SAYING
NO DISCUSSION OF A CLERK LIBERAL.
ON MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROADS HIGH THAT I SEVENTY
TWO NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS.
R. CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM TWENTY THREE IS AB
SIXTEEN THIRTY NINE CORKERY.
AS SOME PEOPLE SIXTEEN THIRTY
NINE BY SOME A MEMBER EDUARDO
GARCIA AND ACTUALLY TO CRIME
VICTIMS [inaudible]
MR GARCIA.
THE MISSISSIPPI IN COLLEGE AB
SIXTEEN THIRTY NINE IS A BILL
THAT WOULD I'M REQUIRE EVERY LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY TO PROVIDE
THE BOARD.
OF THE VICTIMS COMPENSATION
BOARD.
INFORMATION OF THE VICTIMS CRIME
LIAISON OFFICER AND WOULD
REQUIRE THE BOARD TO CONDUCT
OUTREACH TO LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES ABOUT THEIR
DUTY.
PURSUANT TO THE PROVISIONS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR RIVAL.
THANK YOU MISS GARCIA SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CARCLUB THE ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF VOTE
[inaudible]
CLICK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE VOTE I
SEVENTY KNOWS ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM.
TWENTY FOR AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
TWO BY MISTER MURATSUCHI.
CARPOOL RATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MURATSUCHI
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
STATE GOVERNMENT.
WHICH MURATSUCHI THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE IS YOUR OPPORTUNITY
TO ONCE AGAIN DECLARE SURFING IS
CALIFORNIA'S OFFICIAL SPORT.
BILL INCLUDES AN AMENDED
ADDITIONAL FINDING.
STRONG BIPARTISAN SUPPORT NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOU AYE VOTE.
THERE IS WERE SEEKING.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
COR GLOBAL ROLL-ON ALL MEMBERS
VOTE.
WE DECIDED THAT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE ABOUT I
SIXTY TWO KNOWS THREE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT AND
WELL I'M TWENTY FIVE IS AB.
SEVENTEEN NINETY SIX CLERK READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY NINETY SIX
BY SOME A MEMBER MURATSUCHI
ACTUALLY THE TENDENCY.
MISTER MERCIER G. THANK YOU
AGAIN MEMBERS AB SEVENTEEN
NINETY SIX BACK FOR CONCURRENCE.
REQUIRING LANDLORDS IT ALL
CITIES INCLUDING RENT CONTROL
CITIES TO ALLOW THE INSTALLATION
OF ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
STATIONS TO BE PAID FOR IN FULL
BY A TENANT.
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS
OR CLARIFYING IN NATURE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT NO OPPOSITION
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS MURATSUCHI SEEN
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
IT IS OUT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE THAT ICE
FIFTY TWO KNOWS EIGHTEEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
OUR CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM
TWENTY SIX IS AB NINETEEN
SEVENTY THREE CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN SEVENTY
THREE BY SOME A MEMBER QUIRK AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY REPORTING
CRIME.
DOCTOR QUIRK YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND MEMBERS A.
B..
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE BOB
DEFINES WHO IS A MANDATED
REPORTER.
THE CASE OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
IN PARTICULAR IT RESUME.
IT REMOVES AN AMBIGUITY THAT
YEAH SO WE WILL MAKE SURE THAT
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICE
PROVIDERS.
ARE IN FACT.
REPORTERS.
THANK YOU THIS VOTE HAS THIS
BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU DOCTOR QUIRK MS RUBIO
HERE RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AS CHAIR OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE
ON DOMESTIC VIOLENCE I RISE
TODAY.
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
BILL IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE ACCORDING
TO THE NATIONAL COALITION
AGAINST DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS ONE OF THE
MOST CHRONICALLY UNDER REPORTED
CRIMES IN AMERICA.
ONLY 25% OF ALL PHYSICAL
ASSAULTS 20% OF ALL RAPES.
AND 50% OF ALL STALKING
PERPETRATOR PERPETRATED AGAINST
FEMALES BY THEIR PARTNERS ARE
ACTUALLY REPORTED TO THE POLICE.
EMERGENCY MEDICAL TECHNICIANS
ARE OFTEN FIRST RESPONDERS IN
INCIDENTS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND CLASSIFYING THEM AS MANDATED
REPORTERS AT THE COMMON SENSE
STEP TOWARDS INCREASING.
THE AMOUNT OF SERVICES AND
SUPPORT.
THAT WE AS SOCIETY PROVIDE TO
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SURVIVORS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK MY COLLEAGUES
FOR THEIR SUPPORT ON THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE.
THANK YOU MS RUBIO.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION.
CLERK LOCAL ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE.
ZARA VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROADS HIGH THAT I SEVENTY
FIVE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN PASS RETAIN ON
FILE ITEM.
TWENTY SEVEN WE ARE AT FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT AB.
TWENTY SIXTY TWO AYE MR
MAIENSCHEIN CORKERY.
SOME EVIL TWENTY SIXTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAIENSCHEIN AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE STATE
HIGHWAYS.
WHICH MAIENSCHEIN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AB TWENTY SIXTY
TWO WAS AMENDED IN THE SENATE TO
MAKE MINOR CLARIFYING CHANGES.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
NEIGHBORS MAIENSCHEIN SEE NO
DISCUSSION BAY.
CLERK WILL OPEN ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTE.
IS OUT OF THAT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE THAT I
SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
WHERE FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
NINE AB TWENTY ONE OH FIVE CLERK
READ?
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE OH FIVE
BY SOME A MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN AND
OTHERS AND I KIND OF PUNITIVE
DAMAGES.
SHE MAIENSCHEIN YOU MAY GET OPEN
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
TWENTY ONE OH FIVE WAS AMENDED
IN THE SENATE TO MAKE CAR BUYING
CHANGES. TO BENEFIT THE VICTIMS
OF SEXUAL EXPLOITATION THIS WILL
PROVIDE A PROVEN AND EFFECTIVE
TOOL TO ADDRESS THE DEMAND OF
COMMERCIAL SEXUAL EXPLOITATION
OF CHILDREN.
THANK YOU KNOW RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU AGAIN MR MAIENSCHEIN
SINGH NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
QUIRK LOCAL ROLL-ON MEMBERS.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
LOW'S ROLL TIDE OF AND I SEVENTY
THREE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTY AB
TWENTY ONE OH NINE CORPORATE
GREED.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE ó
NINE BY SOME THE MEMBER
O'DONNELL AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO PEOPLE'S.
MISTER O'DONNELL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
TWENTY ONE ON NINE IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THAT
CHILDREN WITH SERIOUS ILLNESSES
ARE ABLE TO ACCESS.
EDUCATIONAL SERVICES IN A TIMELY
MANNER THROUGH HOME OR HOSPITAL
INSTRUCTION.
SENATE ARE TECHNICAL IN NATURE
AND AYE ASPIRIN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER O'DONNELL SING
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLARK WELL OVER THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARKE WELL.
CLOSER ROLL TIDE THAT I SEVENTY
THREE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
WE OUR ASSETS FILE ITEM.
THIRTY ONE AB TWENTY ONE NINETY
SIX BY MISTER COOPER CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE
NINETY SIX BY SOMEONE MEMBER
COOPER AND ACTUALLY PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT.
MISTER COOPER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
SAID AMENDMENTS TO A THEREFORE.
THE BILL SPONSORED BY CALPERS
AND PASSES HEALTH AND CONSENT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THE ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSER ROLL TIDE OF
AND I SEVENTY THREE NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS.
ARE CONCURRENT AND FILE ITEMS
THIRTY TWO AND THIRTY THREE PASS
AND RETAIN THAT BRINGS US TO
FILE ITEM.
THIRTY FOUR AB TWENTY TO FORTY
NINE CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY TO FORTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY AND
ACTUALLY A PUBLIC CONTRACTS
MISTER COOLEY.
COLLEAGUES ARE RISE TO PRESENT
AB TWENTY TO FORTY NINE THIS IS
A MEASURE THAT INCREASES THE
DOLLAR THRESHOLDS. FOR IN
CERTAIN CONGRESS GO OUT TO BID.
THESE THRESHOLDS ARE NOT BEEN
UPDATED SINCE --
TWENTY ELEVEN IT'S A NON
CONTROVERSIAL BILL HAD UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT AYE ROGER AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS COOLEY SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CABALLERO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESERT VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLL TIDE WHEN I SEVENTY
NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM THIRTY FIVE IS PASS
RETAIN.
WHERE FILE ITEM THIRTY SIX AB
TWENTY THREE FIFTY SEVEN
CORPOREAL?
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE FIFTY
SEVEN BY SOME A MEMBER VOEPEL
AND ACTUALLY GET DRIVERS
LICENSES.
ISSUE VOEPEL.
MEMBERS TODAYI PRESENT TO YOU
AB TWENTY THREE FIFTY SEVEN THAT
IS ON CONCURRENCE.
THIS MAJOR REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES
DELTA MIKE VICTOR. TO NOTIFY
APPLICANTS FOR DRIVERS LICENSE
RENEWAL IN WRITING IF THEY WILL
BE REQUIRED TO RETAKE THE
WRITTEN EXAM.
THIS BILL PROVIDES ADVANCE
NOTICE FOR APPLICANTS TO PER
PAIR FOR THE TEST SENATE
AMENDMENTS MAKE MINOR TECHNICAL
CHANGES WITH THIS SAID MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY.
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU FOR THAT DOOZY ASSN
SIR VOEPEL.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
COR CLUB THE ROLL-ON ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE TIE THAT I
SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN FILE
ITEM.
THIRTY SEVEN CB [inaudible]
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY COOPERATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE FIFTY
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER WEBER AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY PRESENCE.
DR WEBER YOU MAY OPEN YES MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS A. B. --
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY IS BACK FROM
THE SENATE FOR CONCURRENCE THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ADDED A CO
AUTHOR AND SPECIFY THAT IF
THERE'S A RISK OF ESCAPE.
NO FEMALE CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS
ARE AVAILABLE TO CONDUCT A
SEARCH IN A MALE CORRECTION
OFFICER MAY CONDUCT PAT DOWN
SEARCHES A FEMALE INCARCERATED
PERSONS.
HIS BILL IS RECEIVED NO NO VOTES
AND HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHERE YOU AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU TO WHOEVER SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLICK LOCAL ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE BUT I
SEVENTY THREE NO.
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
WHERE FILE ITEM THIRTY EIGHT AB
[inaudible]
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY BY SOME THE NUMBER BLOOM
AND ACTUALLY THE FAMILY LAW.
MR BLOOM YOU MAY OPEN MISTER
SPEAKER THANK YOU I'M MEMBERS
I'M PRESENTING ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY FOR
CONCURRENCE THE BILL EXPANDS THE
AVAILABILITY OF VOCATIONAL
EVALUATORS.
IN FAMILY COURT PROCEEDINGS IT
WAS PREVIOUSLY A CONSENT BILL
COMES BACK WITH THEM.
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS
IMPLEMENTATION CONCERNS THIS
BILL IS HAVE NO OPPOSITION AS
RECEIVE NO NO VOTES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS BLOOM SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLARK LOCAL ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE
THIS OUT OF VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TELL YOU BUT I
SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN PASS
RETAIN ON FILE AND THIRTY NINE
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM.
FORTY AB THIRTY TWO TWENTY FOUR
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY TWO TWENTY
FOUR BY SOME A MEMBER THURMOND
AND ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC SOCIAL
SERVICES.
MISTER THURMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ARE RISE PRESENT AB
THIRTY TWO TWENTY FOUR FOR
CONCURRENCE BY THIS MEASURE
WOULD PROHIBIT CERTAIN COUNTY
PROVISIONS.
POSITIONS FROM BEING PRIVATIZED
SPECIFICALLY THE POSITIONS OF
ELIGIBILITY WORKERS IN THE MEDI
CAL CAL FRESH IN CAO WORKS
POSITION POSITIONS --
AS OF LATE THERE HAS BEEN A
MOVEMENT AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL TO
ALLOW COUNTIES TO PRIVATIZE
THESE POSITIONS A WE KNOW THAT
DOING SO.
IN ALLOWING THE PROFIT MOTIVE TO
DRIVE WHAT HAPPENS IN THESE
AGENCIES COULD CAUSE OUR HARM A
TO SOME OF OUR NEEDIEST CITIZENS
AND THAT'S WHY THIS BILL SAYS.
THAT WE SHOULD PRESERVE AND
ENSURE THAT THESE POSITIONS ARE
FILLED BY OUR PUBLIC SERVANTS --
WHO CARE ABOUT HELPING OUR
NEEDIEST CALIFORNIANS ARE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE?
I THINK I MISSED THURMOND SEEN
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
CLERK LOCAL ROCK ALL MEMBERS
VOTE.
SARAH VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
QUIRK WELL CLOSER ROLE TOWN
ABOUT ICE. FIFTY THREE KNOWS.
TWENTY SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEMS FORTY ONE THROUGH
FORTY FIVE PASS A RETAIN.
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM
FORTY SIX AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY
NINE CORPOREAL.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
TWENTY NINE BY SOME THE MEMBER
OBERNOLTE AND ACTUALLY THE
SPECIAL DISTRICTS MISTER
OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
TWENTY THREE TWENTY NINE IS BACK
FOR CONCURRENCE THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES A SINGLE STATEWIDE
STANDARD FOR THE COMPENSATION OF
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICT.
BOARD MEMBERS SENATE AMENDMENTS
CLARIFY THAT IF A BOARD
INCREASES THE NUMBER OF MEETINGS
THE BOARD IS REQUIRED TO JUSTIFY
THE NEED FOR THOSE EGGS EXTRA
MEANINGS.
THIS IS COMMONSENSE LEGISLATION
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIE THAT I
SEVENTY THREE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN. ONE
PASS RETAIN ON FILE ITEM FORTY
SEVEN WE'RE GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY.
ON FILE ITEM FORTY EIGHT AND
MOVED TO FILE ITEM.
FORTY NINE THAT IS AB TWENTY
FIVE FORTY EIGHT BY THIS
FRIEDMAN CORKERY.
SOME LEGAL TWENTY FIVE FORTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN
ACTUALLY TO TRANSPORTATION THIS
FRIEDMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AMENDMENTS MADE TO AB TWENTY
FIVE FORTY EIGHT IN THE SENATE
THE FOLLOWING AUTHORIZE LA METRO
TO REVISE ANY COMMUTER BENEFIT
ORDINANCE THEY ADOPT.
AND AT THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY TO THE
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEES RECEIVING
THE REQUIRED REPORT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON CONCURRENCE.
NAMES FRIEDMAN SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTE.
THIS ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO THOUGH.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT EYES FIFTY
ONE KNOWS FIFTEEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN. FOR
THE PAST RETAIN ON FILE ITEM
FIFTY IT BRINGS US FILE ITEM
FIFTY ONE AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY
NINE CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX SIXTY
NINE BY SOME A MEMBER JONES
SAWYER AND ACTUALLY THE PEACE
OFFICERS MISTER JONES SAWYER.
THANK YOU AB TWENTY SIX SIXTY
NUYS BACK IN THE ASSEMBLY FOR
CONCURRENCE IN MEMBERS TAKEN ON
THE SENATE SIDE DELETED CDC OUR
OFFICE OF CORRECTIONAL SAFETY
FROM THIS BILL.
AND NARROW THE SCOPE OF THE BILL
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER JONES SAWYER
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
OUR CLUB MOREAU.
I'M.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
FEDERAL SIDE OF OF ALL MEMBERS
VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLAIRE TWELVE CLOSER ROLE.
AND TELL YOU THAT I SEVENTY FIVE
NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM FIFTY TWO IS AB TWENTY
SEVEN TEN CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN TEN
BY SOME A MEMBER OBERNOLTE AND
ACTUALLY THE CRIMINAL PROCEDURE.
MISTER OBERNOLTE THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AB TWENTY SEVEN
TEN ALLOWS ELECTRONIC ARREST
WARRANTS TO BE ISSUED IN
CALIFORNIA SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
TECHNICAL IN CLARIFYING AND
REMOVE ALL OPPOSITION.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLARK WELL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE.
IT IS OUR TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLES TALLY
VOTE I SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN FILE ITEM.
FIFTY THREE AB TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTEEN CORKERY.
AT SOME LEVEL TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LACKEY AND ACTUALLY TO DRIVING
UNDER THE INFLUENCE MISTER
LACKEY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTEEN WILL
CONFORM CALIFORNIA'S DI Y. LAS
WITH THE TWENTY SIXTEEN RULING.
MADE BY THE U. S. SUPREME COURT.
CALIFORNIA'S DO YOU WHY LAWS ARE
CURRENTLY NOT IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THE DUE PROCESS REQUIREMENTS AS
SET FORTH BY THE US SUPREME
COURT IN THE BIRCH FIELD VERSUS
NORTH DAKOTA CASE.
THE COURT RULED THAT ALLOWING
CRIMINAL SANCTIONS FOR REFUSING
A BLOOD TEST VIOLATES A PERSON'S
DUE PROCESS RIGHTS.
AB TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTEEN IS A
TECHNICAL FIX AND SIMPLY REMOVED
FROM THE CURRENT STATUTE
CRIMINAL SANCTIONS.
ON A SUSPECTED DUI DRIVER FOR
REFUSING A BLOOD TEST.
UPDATING THE STATURE WILL ALLOW
THE DMV.
I THINK THAT'S DAVID MERRY
VICTOR TO UPDATE THE NECESSARY
FORMS TO REFLECT THIS CHANGE.
THE LAW WILL ENSURE THAT ALL LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS COMPLYING WITH
THE COURT'S RULING AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
NAMES LIKE MISTER COOLEY URANUS
COLLEAGUES EMPLOYEES RISES
SUPPORT THIS BILL I URGE YOU ALL
TO VOTE YANKEE ECHO SIERRA.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS.
SARAH VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
A DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE AND HOW ON I SEVENTY
FIVE NO.
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN MEMBERS OR TO MOVE
BACK IN THE FILE TO FILE ITEM.
FORTY EIGHT IS FILE ITEM FORTY
EIGHT AB [inaudible]
TWENTY FOUR THIRTY NINE CORKERY.
S. A LITTLE TWENTY FOUR THIRTY
NINE BY SOME THE MEMBER EDUARDO
GARCIA AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
STATE MEMORIALS.
MR GARCIA THE USER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AB TWENTY FOUR THIRTY
NINE WOULD CLAIRE AND DESIGNATE
THE LGBTQ VETERAN MEMORIAL.
IN THE CITY OF GOOD PEOPLE CITY.
THIS WOULD BE THE FIRST IN THE
NATION AND CERTAINLY IN THE
STATE TO RECOGNIZE LGBTQ
VETERANS.
ACROSS THE COUNTRY FOR THEIR
SACRIFICE AND DEDICATION TO THIS
GREAT COUNTRY RESPECT MASTERY
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CO SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE RIGHT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THESE ARE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE TALLY THAT I
SIXTY TWO NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT AND ON
RECONSIDERATION FILE ITEMS FIFTY
NINE SIXTY AND SIXTY ONE WILL BE
CONTINUED
.
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING.
THIRD READING FILE ITEM SIX TWO
THROUGH.
SIXTY SIX HOUSE AND RETAIN.
THIS BRINGS US TO THE SENATE
THIRD READING FILE FILE ITEM.
SIXTY SEVEN THROUGH.
SEVENTY EIGHT PASS AND RETAIN
THIS IS SENATE THIRD READING
FILE.
WE DO HAVE AMENDMENTS FOR FILE
ITEM.
SEVENTY NINE S. JAAFAR.
TWELVE THE CLERK WILL READ WITH
AMENDMENTS.
SENATE RESOLUTION WITH
AMENDMENTS BY FAMILY MEMBER
MEDINA.
MR MEDINA ON THE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TO PRESENT TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS
TO S. J. R..
TWELVE BY SENATOR WIENER.
SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION TWELVE
BY SENATOR WIENER CALLS UPON THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO RESTORE
FULL FUNDING TO THE FULBRIGHT U.
S. STUDENT PROGRAM.
THESE AMENDMENTS MERELY UPDATE
STATISTICS OUR FULBRIGHT AWARD
IS TO REFLECT RECENT DATA
PUBLISHED.
IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON THE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU MR MEDINA.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT.
THE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED.
RESOLUTION OUT PRINTING BACK ON
FILE.
FILE ITEMS EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY
THREE PASS RETAIN.
FILE ITEM.
EIGHTY FOUR WORD FILE ITEM
EIGHTY FOUR THIS IS S. B. NINE
THIRTEEN CORKERY.
SEVERAL NINE THIRTEEN BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC WORKS
[inaudible]
SURE BLOW.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER --
MEMBERS SO UNFORTUNATELY THERE'S
A LOT OF GRAFFITI IN LOS ANGELES
WE FIND IT ON BILLBOARDS GARAGE
DOORS BRIDGES AND BUS STOPS AND
LEFT UNABATED I'M SURE YOU ARE
ALL UNDERSTAND AND KNOW THAT
GRAFFITI LOWERS HOME PRICES
INCREASES VANDALISM DECREASES
THE SENSE OF SAFETY.
STRAINED SOCIAL COHESION AND
AFFECT THE PERCEPTION OF SELF
WORTH.
IN SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN SO
UNDERSTANDING THECRITICAL NEED
TO CLEAN UP GRAFFITI BUT UNABLE
TO HANDLE THE VOLUME OF GRAFFITI
ON A THAT EXISTS IN.
THE CITY OF LA LOS ANGELES FIRST
CONTRACTED WITH COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS TO PROVIDE
GRAFFITI ABATEMENT SERVICES BACK
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE AND FOR
ALMOST THREE DECADES.
THESE ORGANIZATIONS HAVE NOW
PROVIDED ABATEMENT SERVICES AS A
COST SAVINGS FOR THE CITY WERE
SPENDS ABOUT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR.
DEALING WITH GRAFFITI AND IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN SCRUB AWAY.
OF THESE ORGANIZATIONS SCRUB
AWAY ABOUT THIRTY MILLION FEET
OF GRAFFITI.
APPLICATION OF THE DIRECTOR OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS
DETERMINATION THAT GRAFFITI
REMOVAL SERVICES ARE A PUBLIC
WORKS PROJECT AND THEREFORE MUST
BE CONTRACTED AT THE LOCAL
PREVAILING WAGE.
UNFORTUNATELY REDUCES GRAFFITI
ABATEMENT PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT
THE CITY.
AND THIS BILL.
THEREFORE CREATES A NARROW
EXEMPTION FROM PREVAILING WAGE
ONLY FOR GRAFFITI ABATEMENT WORK
PERFORMED BY NONPROFIT COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS IN THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES.
S. B. NINE THIRTEEN ALSO OPENS A
NEW PATH TO EMPLOYMENT BY
CREATING A PARTNERSHIP THROUGH A
PRE APPRENTICESHIP TRAINING.
PROGRAM WITHOUT LEGISLATIVE
ACTION THERE WILL BE GREAT
REDUCTION IN THE CURRENT
GRAFFITI REMOVAL PROGRAM AND
THAT WILL BE DETRIMENTAL TO THE
NEIGHBORHOODS AND BUSINESS
CORRIDOR SERVED BY THIS PROGRAM.
THE BILL SUPPORTED BY STE A
NUMBER OF COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES AND DISTRICT
SIXTEEN OF THE INTERNATIONAL
UNION OF PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR IBOOK.
THANK YOU MISTER BLOW.
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLL TIDE VOTE EYES FIFTY
NINE KNOWS NINE THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
FILE ITEMS EIGHTY FIVE AND
EIGHTY SIX HOUSE TO RETAIN.
WE ARE AT FILE ITEM. EIGHTY
SEVEN THIS IS S. C. ARE.
ONE TWENTY ONE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
TWENTY ONE BY SENATOR ANDERSON
AND OTHERS BOLTED TO THE EAGLE
STAFF [inaudible]
MISS WALDRON.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
AS SEE ARE.
ONE TWENTY ONE WHICH RECOGNIZES
THE HISTORY AND SIGNIFICANCE OF
THE EAGLE STAFF TO NATIVE
AMERICAN TRIBES.
THE EAGLE STAFF IS USED TO
REPRESENT TRIBAL SOVEREIGNTY.
UNITY AND TRADITION TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES NATIVE AMERICAN AND
FIRST NATIONS ORGANIZATIONS OR A
MEMBER OF AN HONOR SOCIETY OR
SERVICE VETERAN.
THE EAGLE STAFFERS THE
PROFLIGACY OF THE NATIVE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TO REAFFIRM
CALIFORNIA'S COMMITMENT TO
INCLUSIVENESS FOR ALL NATIVE
AMERICANS.
THE TRADITIONS AND SYMBOLISM OF
THE EAGLE STAFF ACR ONE TWENTY
ONE SEEKS TO RECOGNIZE THE EAGLE
STAFF OF THE FIRST FLAG.
OF SOMEONE NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBAL NATIONS AND FIRST NATIONS
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS WALDRON WOULD YOU
LIKE CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION [inaudible]
PLEASE.
AVERAGE THE FIRST ROLE WILL BE
OPEN FOR A CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS THIS IS FOR
COAUTHORS ON SCR. ONE TWENTY ONE
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
ON THE RESOLUTION [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL THEIR SEVENTY ONE CO
AUTHORS ADDITIVE WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE
IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
WE ARE ON THE SENATE THIRD
READING FILE FILE ITEMS EIGHTY
EIGHT THROUGH.
NINETY SEVEN PASS AND RETAIN.
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM
NINETY EIGHT SP.
FOUR EIGHTY ONE CORKERY.
SENATE BILL FOUR EIGHTY ONE BY
SENATOR PAN AND ACTUALLY THE
REDEVELOPMENT [inaudible]
MR MCCARTY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THIS IS
A DISTRICT BILL OF COURSE IN MY
DISTRICT AND THAT THAT SENATOR
PAN WHICH WOULD EXPAND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES
WITHIN THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO.
RELATED TO THE DISPOSITION OF
REDEVELOPMENT PROPERTIES THIS
WOULD ALLOW THE COUNTIES
REDEVELOPMENT [inaudible]
EXCESS REGENCY. TO SELL A
PROPERTY FOR BELOW MARKET VALUE
IF THAT PROPERTY GOES FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT CONSTRUCTION OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AYE I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT NO
OPPOSITION AND BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT ALONG THE WAY THANK YOU.
NAME IS CARD SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLARK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLICK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TIED ABOUT ICE FIFTY
ONE KNOWS.
TWENTY THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEMS NINETY NINE AND ONE
HUNDRED AS WELL AS ONE HUNDRED
AND ONE PASS AND RETAIN THAT
BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM.
ONE OH TO S. C. ARE [inaudible]
ONE FORTY SIX CLEVER READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
FORTY SIX BY SENATOR MCGUIRE AND
OTHERS ABILITY TO CAL FAIRGROUND
FLOWER MONTH [inaudible]
MS OWEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER TODAY I
AM PLEASED TO PRESENT AS HE OUR
ONE FORTY SIX WHICH DECLARES A
JUNE TWENTY EIGHTEEN US
CALIFORNIA GROWN FLOWER MONTH.
TO RECOGNIZE THE FLOWER INDUSTRY
WE HAVE IN THE STATE AND ITS
CONTINUED PRODUCTIVITY.
CALIFORNIA'S FLOWER INDUSTRY
DATES BACK TO THE LATE EIGHTEEN
SEVENTIES AND TO THIS DAY THE
STATE'S PERFECT YEAR ROUND
CLIMATE.
ALLOWS FOR GROWING OF HUNDREDS
OF VARIETIES OF FLOWERS.
CLOWER FLOWERS ACROSS IT GROWN
ACROSS CALIFORNIA FROM SAN DIEGO
THROUGH THE INLAND EMPIRE TO THE
COASTAL CITIES OF OXNARD IN
CAMERINO ALL THE WAY TO THE
OREGON BORDER.
CALIFORNIA IS THE LARGEST
PRODUCING STATE OF FRESH CUT
FLOWERS IN THE COUNTRY
REPRESENTING OVER 80% OF ALL CUT
FLOWERS GROWN IN THE UNITED
STATES.
IN MY OWN DISTRICT THERE ARE
OVER TWENTY FLOWER FARMS GROWING
OF VARIETY OF FLOWERS INCLUDING
SUNFLOWERS CALLA LILIES AND SNAP
DRAGONS.
CALIFORNIA'S CUT FLOWER INDUSTRY
NOT ONLY PROVIDES BEAUTY TO THE
WORLD BUT ALSO CREATES.
A 1-004-500-0600 AND SIXTY FIVE
JOBS GENERATING TWELVE POINT TWO
BILLION IN BUSINESS ACTIVITY.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN RECOGNIZING
THIS GREAT [inaudible]
EXCESS.
AND I ASK THAT THE FIRST ROLE BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MISTER WHEN SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE MISTER ONCE
ASSN FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS CLERK WILL HAVE THEIR
OWN.
NEMESIS IS CO AUTHORS ON SCR ONE
FORTY SIX THIS IS CO AUTHORS.
COAUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE RATHER SEVENTY TWO CO
AUTHORS ADDED WITHOUT OBJECTION.
WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION.
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
BY.
OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
FILE ITEMS ONE OF THREE THROUGH
ONE OH FIVE HOUSE RETAIN.
MEMBERS WE ARE FILE ITEM.
ONE OH SIX THIS IS S. B. TO
SEVENTY THREE FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS KERKORIAN WITH
AMENDMENTS.
SENATE BILL TWO SEVENTY THREE
WITH AMENDMENTS BY FAMILY MEMBER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER MISS GONZALEZ
FLETCHER ON THE AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
SP TWO THIRTY SEVEN WILL PROTECT
MINERS FROM BEING FORCED OR
COERCED INTO MARRIAGE BY
PROVIDING INCREASED COURT
OVERSIGHT.
THESE AMENDMENTS CLARIFY THE
COLLECTION PROCESS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
ANNUAL REPORT ON THE NUMBER OF
MARRIAGES INVOLVING A MINOR
INCLUDING PRIVACY PROVISIONS.
THE AMENDMENTS ALSO NARROWED
EXEMPTION FOR SIXTEEN AND
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS FROM A
THIRTY DAY WAIT PERIOD BETWEEN
WHEN A COUPLE GETS A COURT ORDER
APPROVED WHEN THEIR MARRIAGE
LICENSE CAN BE FINALIZED TO ONLY
CASES WHERE AN INDIVIDUAL IS
PREGNANT.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
SEE NO DISCUSSION BETA WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE.
ON THE MEMBERS ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS
ARE ADOPTED.
THE BILL IS.
HOW TO PRINT AND BACK ON FILE?
FILE ITEMS ONE OH SEVEN THROUGH.
ONE TWENTY PASS AND RETAIN.
THAT BRINGS US TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
DOES ANY MEMBER WISH TO REMOVE
AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE THE
CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND DAY
CONSENT CALENDAR.
SENATE BILL EIGHT NINETY TWO BY
SENATOR PAN AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE WRONG THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS ADDED VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE YOUR OWN TIME ABOUT AYE
AND SEVENTY FOUR NOS ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
THE CLERK WILL READ THE
REMAINING ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
AND SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION.
TWENTY I SEVENTY FOUR KNOWS.
ZERO MEMBERS AS YOUR BILLS
APPEAR ON THE THIRD READING FILE.
IN THE SENATE DAILY FILE PLEASE
DESIGNATE A FLOOR MANAGER.
PLEASE DESIGNATE A FLOOR MANAGER
AS YOUR BILLS APPEAR ON THIRD
READING OF THE SENATE DAILY FILE.
SO THEY MAY PRESENT YOUR BILLS
ON THE SENATE FLOOR.
PLEASE NOTIFY THE SENATE TO ASK.
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
TUESDAY AUGUST SEVENTH CHECK IN
SESSION.
WEDNESDAY AUGUST EIGHTH CHECK IN
SESSION THURSDAY AUGUST NINTH
[inaudible]
FLOOR SESSION.
IS AT NINE A. M. MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING TO ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
AND MEMBERS IF FAME IF I MAY
PLEASE HAVE YOUR ATTENTION.
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY WOMAN
AGUIAR-CURRY IN THE ASSEMBLY AT
LARGE.
MEMBERS PLEASE RISE AS WE
OBSERVE A MOMENT OF SILENCE. FOR
THE VICTIMS OF THE RECENT FIRES.
IN AND AROUND MISS AGUILAR
CURRIES DISTRICT [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
A MOMENT OF SILENCE
.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT ADJOURNMENTS
IN MEMORY.
I WOULD ASK THAT YOU PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS.
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE FLOOR WE ARE GOING TO
START WITH MR HOLDEN.
MEMBERS QUORUM CALL IS IN PLACE.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
OR REMOVE YOUR CONVERSATIONS
FROM THE FLOOR.
PLEASE GIVE YOUR RESPECTFUL
ATTENTION. TO MR HOLDEN.
MR HOLDEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS I RISE
TODAY. TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY
OF RONALD V. DELLUMS.
DELLUMS PASSED AWAY IN HIS HOME
IN WASHINGTON AFTER A BATTLE
WITH CANCER ON JULY THIRTIETH.
RON DELLUMS HAD A LIFETIME
COMMITMENT TO PUBLIC SERVICE.
OVER THE SPAN OF HIS CAREER.
HE SERVED AS A BERKELEY CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER A US CONGRESS
MEMBER.
AND MAYOR OF OAKLAND.
DELLUMS WAS NEVER AFRAID TO
STAND UP FOR WHAT HE BELIEVED
AND ANY OFTEN FACED CRITICISM.
FOR HE NEVER WAVERED ON HIS
ANTIWAR BELIEVES THAT HE WENT TO
GREAT LENGTHS TO SUPPORT THE END
OF VIOLENCE AND SOCIAL INJUSTICE
ACROSS THE GLOBE.
DELLUMS WAS A FOUNDING MEMBER OF
THE CONGRESSIONAL BLACK CAUCUS
WHICH HE CHAIRED FROM. NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE TO NINETEEN NINETY
ONE AND ADVOCATED FOR SPENDING
ON EDUCATION JOBS HOUSING
HEALTHCARE ASSISTANCE FOR THE
POOR AND PROGRAMS TO FIGHT DRUG
ABUSE.
IF DELLUMS GREAT LEGACY CAN
TEACH US ANYTHING.
IS THAT WE MUST BE FEARLESS.
AND A BIT RADICAL OURSELVES.
IN PURSUIT OF ALL THINGS THAT
MISTER SPEAKER US AND OUR
COLLECTIVE CONDOLENCES TO HIS
FAMILY.
AND CLOSE FRIENDS FOR THE GREAT
LOSS OF THIS CALIFORNIA ICON RON
DELLUMS.
THANK YOU MISTER HOLDEN.
MR THURMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I I TO RISE IN AND
JOINING OF MY COLLEAGUES FROM
PASADENA.
BUT MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS AND
OTHERS I TO ASK THAT WE
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY.
OF A FORMER CONGRESSMAN OUT
RONALD B. DELLUMS I'M I WOULD
START OFF BY SAYING --
CONGRESSMAN DELLUMS WAS AN
AMAZING PUBLIC SERVANT WHO WE
HAD OF THE PLEASURE OF HAVING
SERVE US IN CONGRESS FOR MORE
THAN TWENTY SEVEN YEARS --
HE SERVICE COUNTRY FIRST AS A
MARINE --
AND AS YOU HEARD SERVED ON THE
CITY COUNCIL AND SERVED IN
CONGRESS BUT BEFORE THAT HE
SERVED AS A SOCIAL WORKER IN HIS
COMMUNITY.
AND FOR SOMEONE WHO WAS ALSO IN
SOCIAL WORK --
BEFORE POLITICS HE SOMEONE WHO I
OFTEN LOOKED UP.
TO ESPECIALLY HIS WORK --IN NINETEEN NINETY TWO LEAD
EFFORTS TO A AND APARTHEID IN
SOUTH AFRICA.
IN AS A STUDENT ON A COLLEGE
CAMPUS -- WE
ALL WATCHED --
AS HE SAID THAT WE SHOULD DIVEST
ALL MONEY OUT OF OUR UNIVERSITY
AND OTHER INSTITUTIONS OUT OF A
GOVERNMENT THAT THAT DID NOT
RECOGNIZE.
BLACK APPLICANTS SHOULD HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE --
<c.green> WAS A VERY GENEROUS MAN</c>
WITH THIS TIME.
AND I'M FORTUNATE TO HAVE HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY I DO HAVE HAVE
HAD HIS COUNSEL.
ON HIS GUIDANCE HIS MENTORSHIP
AND HIS WISDOM THE LAST FEW
YEARS AYE HE TURNED HIS WORK
ALMOST EXCLUSIVELY. TO OP
MENTORING PUBLIC SERVANTS AND
HELPING YOUNG PEOPLE TO ENTER
INTO THE SPACE OF PUBLIC SERVICE
IN THE CREATED.
THE RONALD B. DELLUMS INSTITUTE
UP FOR THAT PURPOSE --
AS YOU HEARD HE WAS A
TRAILBLAZER WHO HELPED TO CREATE
A LEGACY OF AFRICAN AMERICAN
ELECTED OFFICIALS AND OTHERS --
BUT MANY WHO HAVE SERVED I IN
THE SAME HOUSE I LIKE FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANDRA SWANSON.
FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER ELIHU
HARRIS ASSEMBLYMEMBER SENATOR
AND NOW CONGRESSWOMAN AND ALSO
SOCIAL WORKER AND CHAMPION
CONGRESSWOMAN BARBARA LEE --
CONGRESSMAN DELLUMS ALWAYS
LIFTED UP.
THE RIGHTS IN NEEDS OF THOSE WHO
ARE THE MOST VULNERABLE IN OUR
NATION.
WAS BORN IN WEST OAKLAND IS A
GRADUATE OF OAKLAND TECH HIGH
SCHOOL SAN FRANCISCO STATE UC
BERKELEY.
AYE AND SERVED HIS COMMUNITY OFF
FOR MANY YEARS FIRST ON THE CITY
COUNCIL AS A CONGRESSMAN FOR
TWENTY SEVEN YEARS.
AND THEN LAST AS THE MAYOR OF
THE GREAT CITY OF OAKLAND.
AYE WE ARRIVED IN DC IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY ONE HE MADE THE PROTESTS
OF WAR HIS TOP PRIORITY.
AND CONTINUE TO MAKE SURE THAT
OUR GOVERNMENT AND OUR MILITARY
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
ALLOWING --
FOR THE FUTURE INTEGRATION OF
GAYS AND LESBIANS INTO MILITARY
SERVICE.
I AS MAYOR OF OAKLAND HE BROUGHT
MILLIONS OF FEDERAL DOLLARS TO
HELP RECRUIT LOCAL TEACHERS.
SUPPORT PROGRAMS TO COMBAT
TRUANCY AND HIGH DROPOUT RATES A
LAUNCH THE OAKLAND PROMISE.
I IN TWO THOUSAND NINE HE
BROUGHT SIXTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS OF STIMULUS MONEY A TO
THE CITY.
I'M GRATEFUL I TO HIM FOR HIS
COMMITMENT TO WORKING WITH THE
CITIES THROUGHOUT MY SIMPLY
DISTRICT.
AYE WE OFTEN WORK TOGETHER TO
TRY TO FIND WAYS.
TO ADDRESS CRIME AND VIOLENCE
THAT DOES NOT KNOW ANY
BOUNDARIES AND HE WAS VERY
GENEROUS AS MAYOR OF OAKLAND TO
HELP LEAD THAT EFFORT AND TO
SUPPORT ALL OF US IN LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. TO QUOTE HIS
DAUGHTER PIPER.
HE WAS A HERO TO THE INVISIBLE.
TO THE OPPRESSED THE LOST.
SHATTERED THE MARGINALIZE.
SURPRISE AND ABUSE A FACELESS.
FROM THE VICTIM TO THE
INCARCERATED.
FROM THE HEEL TO THE DISABLED
FROM ACTIVISTS TO VETERANS HE
WAS A PEACE MONGER.
MY HEARTFELT CONDOLENCES GO OUT
TO HIS LOVED ONES IN THE ENTIRE
EAST BAY.
COMMUNITY THAT IS MOURNING HIS
LOSS.
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE
CYNTHIA IN FIVE CHILDREN RACHEL
CHAPMAN ARE BRAND AND DELLUMS
ERIK TODD DELLUMS.
PIPER MONIQUE DELLUMS AND CARL
LEWIS A SURVIVOR BY SIX
GRANDCHILDREN. TWO GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN I ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN THE MEMORY OF
CONGRESSMAN OF RONALD BICU
DELLUMS.
THANK GOODNESS THURMOND.
IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION THE
QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED I'M SORRY.
I DIDN'T SEE MS BURKE'S
MICROPHONE IS BURKE YOU ARE TO
RECOGNIZE YOU THINK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS IT'S WITH A
HEAVY HEART THAT I RISE TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF MY FRIEND
DR EDWARD W. SAVAGE JUNIOR.
DOCTOR SAVAGE WAS AN INVALUABLE
MEMBER AND OUR COMMUNITY AFTER
EARNING HIS MENTAL DUKE SCHOOL
DEGREE DOCTORS AVERAGE SERVED AS
A CAPTAIN IN THE U. S. AIR FORCE
FOR TWO YEARS.
AS A MEDICAL PRACTITIONER DOCTOR
SAVAGE PLAYED A CRITICAL ROLE IN
THE FIELD ABOVE SECTOR X. AND
GYNECOLOGY SINCE NINETEEN
SEVENTY THREE HE HAS BEEN A
SIGNIFICANT RESOURCE FOR THE
SOUTH CENTRAL REGION OF LOS
ANGELES.
SOMETIMES ACTING AS HIS ONLY
SOLD CERTIFIED PRACTITIONER
GYNECOLOGICAL ONCOLOGY.
AS AN EDUCATOR HE SERVED AS
CHIEF OF THE DIVISION OF
GYNECOLOGY AT THE CHARLES R.
DREW UNIVERSITY OF MEDICAL
MEDICINE AND SCIENCE AND WOULD
LATER RISE TO SERVE AS THE
MEDICAL DIRECTOR FOR THE
UNIVERSITY.
HIS WORK IN EXPANDING ACCESS TO
THOSE WHO WISH TO PURSUE A
CAREER IN OBSTETRICS AND
GYNECOLOGY ONE HIM
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT AS DISTINGUISHED
ALUMNI OF TALLADEGA COLLEGE BY
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION.
OF EQUAL OPPORTUNITY IN HIGHER
EDUCATION.
HE WILL BE REMEMBERED FONDLY AS
HIS IMPRESSIVE CAREER AND HIS
COMMITMENT TO HIS PUBLIC SERVICE
HAS IMPACTED MANY.
DOCTORS HAVE JUST ABOUT FIVE BY
HIS DEVOTED AND LOVING WIFE
CHILDREN AND GRANDCHILDREN.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT WE
ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY.
THANK YOU MS BURKE.
IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION A
QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED.
AND WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON A GERMAN THE MEMORY.
AND MEMBERS OUT ASK THAT YOU
AGAIN PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS OR
TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF OF
THE FLOOR.
WE HAVE MEMBERS WHO WILL BE A
CHURNING IN THE MEMORY
[inaudible]
MR GIPSON.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMAN IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER.
I RISE TO ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF
TONY RENE ALISON.
WHO WAS BORN ON JANUARY FIFTH?
NINETEEN SEVENTY SHE WAS ACTIVE
COMMUNITY MEMBER IN EAST
STOCKTON WHICH SHE RAISED THREE
CHILDREN.
TONY CREATIVITY LED HER TO
PURSUE A VOCATION AND
PROFESSIONAL EDUCATION.
THROUGH.
OUT HER A CAREER IN COSMETOLOGY
AND TELECOMMUNICATION.
AND SERVE AS A FAMILY SERVICE.
CASE WORKER IN SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY HEAD START.
TONY DEDICATION TO HER FAITH
THAT LED HER TO BECOME A BELOVED
SPIRITUAL LEADER AND SUPPORTER
OF HER HUSBAND'S MINISTRY.
TONY'S PASSION FOR YOUNG PEOPLE
SERVICE AND ACTIVISM.
FUELED HER DEDICATION TO EMPOWER
WOMEN YOUTH AND COMMUNITY.
HAVING VOLUNTEERED AS A DIVISOR
TO THE STOCKTON YOUTH AND
COLLEGE DIVISION OF THE IN
DOUBLE ACP.
EACH OF HER CHILDREN HAS SERVED
AS LEADERS IN SOME CAPACITY
ACROSS OUR COUNTRY.
I HAD THE PLEASURE OF WORKING --
AND NO WORKING WITH HER
DAUGHTERS AFTER THE SMITH WHO
WORKED FOR ME --
AS I CHAIR THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE
AUDIT COMMITTEE --
STEPHANIE WAS EXTRAORDINARY OF
INDIVIDUAL WORKING ON MY TEAM.
I WANT TO THANK HER FOR
INTRODUCED ME TO HER MOTHER
DURING THE TIME SHE WAS --
ILL ON IT EIGHT FORTY EIGHT
YEARS OF AGE TONY LEAVES BEHIND
TO CHERISH HER MEMORY.
HER HUSBAND A WHITE L. JINKINS
JUNIOR.
HER PARENTS DEBBIE JONES --
THREE CHILDREN INCLUDING THIS
HAPPENING A GRAND DAUGHTER ALONG
WITH MANY OTHER.
WHO LOVED HER DEARLY AYE*
BODY TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY?
THANK YOU MISS GIPSON.
MISTER VOEPEL FOR YOUR GERMAN IN
MEMORY [inaudible]
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO ADJOURN
IN THE MEMORY OF ARTHUR DWAYNE
IKE EISENHOWER.
IKE WAS BORN IN MINNESOTA.
ON JANUARY NINETEENTH NINETEEN
THIRTY NINE AND IS SURVIVED BY
HIS WIFE MARILYN.
HIS CHILDREN LAURIE SUSAN
DEBORAH AND ROBERT AND HIS EIGHT
GRANDCHILDREN.
I'VE SERVED IN THE UNITED STATES
NAVY AND I REMIND EVERYONE.
UNITED STATES NAVY IS THE
WORLD'S GREATEST NUCLEAR POWERED
NAVY.
I QUIT A LIKE THAT. FOR OVER
THIRTY YEARS AND HE SETTLED IN
LAKESIDE CALIFORNIA HE HAD MANY
ACCOMPLISHMENTS DURING HIS TIME
OF NAVAL SERVICE.
SUCH AS CONDUCTING RESCUE
MISSIONS BEING SELECTED FOR A
PRESIDENTIAL COMMISSION AND
WORKING WITH UNDERWATER
DEMOLITION TRAINING.
AND DRUG INTERVENTION PROGRAMS.
BUT THE LOVE OF HIS COUNTRY AND
HIS COMMUNITY IS PERHAPS THE
MOST ADMIRABLE.
AFTER RETIRING FROM THE UNITED
STATES NAVY ARE ONCE AGAIN I
REMIND EVERYONE THE GREATEST
NUCLEAR POWERED NAVY IN THE
WORLD.
STILL.
I COULD BE LAUGHED AT THAT.
ONE I JOIN THE LIONS CLUB WHERE
HE DEVOTED HIS TIME VOLUNTARY
BEFORE HE BECAME THE FOUNDER OF
THE RANCHO SANTEE LIONS CLUB.
HE LATER BECAME A MEMBER OF THE
SANTEE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND
ULTIMATELY BECAME PRESIDENT OF
THE CHAMBER.
HE DEDICATED HIS RETIREMENT
VOLUNTARY WILL MULTIPLE
ORGANIZATIONS THE GUY JUST NEVER
QUIT HE NEVER QUIT HE WAS ALWAYS
OUT THERE.
GIVING BACK TO HIS COMMUNITY.
OVER THE YEARS IKE HAS BEEN
PRESENTED WITH NUMEROUS AWARDS
AND PROCLAMATIONS HONORING HIM
FOR HIS DEDICATION AND SERVICE.
THE COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO.
CLAIMED THAT JANUARY TWENTY
THIRD TWO THOUSAND SEVEN BE
OFFICIALLY KNOWN AS IKE
EISENHOWER DAY.
HIS UNWAVERING DEVOTION TO GIVE
HIM BACK TO HIS COMMUNITY IS A
RARE QUALITY AND ONE THAT WILL
BE HERE REPLACEABLE IN OUR
COMMUNITY.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN ADJOURNING IN
THE MEMORY OF MY GOOD FRIEND IKE
EISENHOWER [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER VOEPEL THANK
YOU MEMBERS.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED TO RETAIN ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SEEING HER NO FURTHER BUSINESS
I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION
TO ADJOURN.
MISTER GIPSON MOVES AND MISS
WALDRON SECONDS.
THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL THURSDAY AUGUST NINTH.
AT NINE AM WE ARE ADJOURNED
.
FILE ITEM FORTY NINE AB TWENTY
FIVE FORTY EIGHT WALDRON ITEM NO.
VOTE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WALDRON ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FIVE FORTY EIGHT I DUNNO